all these absolutes now rich people are
all evil but that's not how people work
they vary some are evil some are nice
cops are all bad no some are bad some
are awesome teachers are heroes no some
are heroes and some [__] they're
students
right and that student is a
hero
yeah all right yeah I don't hate any
group I like all the groups you know I
also like racial jokes yeah those kind
of went
away I know I grew up in a promy black
neighborhood I went to public school
with all say horrible things to each
other everybody got along now you can't
make those jokes anymore and we're see
more tense than ever it was fun cut the
tension you know I walk to school they
be like Mark you can't dance I was like
well you can't
swim and we're all still friends of this
day then you get around some stiff white
guys like hey you can't say that I'm
like you don't you don't know our
relationship that's what we do like you
walk in on me choking my wife you're
like call the police like no she loves
that okay you don't always know the
relationship